l'insuffisance rénale l'une des
priorités de la nouvelle stratégie de
santé qui souhaite notamment développer
la prévention de cette maladie chronique
france rhin propose des dépistages
gratuits et anonymes comme ici à la
clinique de saint germain en laye ça
permet de dépister assez tôt les
maladies et de prendre en charge et de
faire un suivi régulier
les patients doivent le faire une perf
en bas c'était l'occasion et je crois
que c'est une bonne opportunité parce
que effectivement à mon âge je pensais
pas forcément ce dépistage dure dix
minutes examen rapide est question sont
au programme
c'est important de prendre et vérifier
la tension pour justement détecter les
maladies cardiaques et également rénale
on leur demande s'ils aussi ils ont des
antécédents familiaux parce que ça joue
beaucoup et puis on fait un recueil de
données donc on l'est pèse on prend
l'inter leur glycémie leur tour de
taille et puis on leur demande d'uriner
dans un pot pour faire une bandelette
urinaire
le service de dialyse de la clinique de
saint germain en laye accueille environ
40 personnes par jour pour une dialyse
de trois à cinq heures suivant la
corpulence de la personne un dépistage
précoce permet une prise en charge
appropriée
letestu rynair permet de détecter toute
trace de sang ou encore de leucocytes
suivant la couleur
ben quand on trempe la bande l'être dans
le green
suivant cette bandelette la machine nous
détecte tous les tous les problèmes
qu'il peut y avoir ou pas de problème la
maladie rénale est dite silencieuse elle
ne se manifeste par aucun symptôme
perceptible en france plus d'un tiers
des personnes entrent en urgence en
traitement de suppléance greffe ou
dialyse le rhin qui ne fonctionne plus
donc on compense cette cette pathologie
en filtrant en fait le sang de la
personne en éliminant l'eau et les
électrolytes une toxiques pour
l'organisme
cette quatorzième semaine nationale du
rein vis plus largement à sensibiliser
le grand public aux problématiques
relatives aux maladies rénales
je pense qu'ils importent important de
sensibiliser les gens à toutes les
maladies parce qu'on
je me le nombre de malades concernés par
l'insuffisance rénale augmentent de 2 %
par an